[Música]
eu queria falar para vocês sobre o
manzini manzini ele é um pesquisador
italiano que disse que a gente se
acostumou a comprar soluções para os
problemas que a gente vive
é como se de alguma forma o recurso
deixasse de ficar disponível
gratuitamente
a gente vai lá no mercado e compra ele
foi assim com a água que por não
confiamos nas limpezas dos rios a gente
recorre pra garrafas plásticas os
filtros ou com segurança buscando os
condomínios fechados
as cercas elétricas e os sistemas
complexos de monitoramento
mas nem sempre foi assim quando e se
essas soluções não estavam disponíveis
ou eram caras
a gente tinha que quebrar a cabeça e
colocar nossa criatividade a prova pra
pensar em soluções
então se não tinha alimentos a gente
podia fazer uma horta
se não tem água uma cisterna segurança
uma onda entre vizinhos
a verdade é que com esse hábito de
compra
a gente se tornou consumidores das
nossas cidades e dos mais exigentes
porque a gente quer calçada limpa
trânsito tranqüilo as ruas seguras
desde que isso seja feito e mantido por
alguém e esse alguém geralmente o
governo e é claro que o governo tem um
papel importante para a gente pensar
nessas soluções e pensar em formas mais
eficientes de como solucionar esses
problemas mas a gente a gente não pode
esperar que o governo sozinho consiga
resolver tudo tá muito complexo né
e afinal nós também somos criadores
desses problemas
mas a boa notícia é que a gente também
pode ser parte das soluções
a gente tem que se entender como um
recurso desse sistema e que também é
possível de melhorá-lo né de influenciá
lo para melhor e aí então é eu fico
pensando o que aconteceria se a gente
deixasse de ser consumidor para se
tornar mais evolutivo né e produtor
o empreendedor da cidade a gente já viu
cases muito legais hoje aqui a gente tem
visto outros no brasil e no mundo que
mostram que é possível sim fazer uma
gestão compartilhada entre os moradores
do poder público no interior do reino
unido por exemplo duas mulheres estavam
incomodar disse mas que a questão da
alimentação no futuro e pensar o que
cada canteiro da cidade pôde se tornar
uma horta
elas foram lá e fizeram um chamamento
público e vieram 60 pessoas
se tivesse 25 ela já tinha a chave do
sucesso é verdade é que com esse grupo
elas conseguiram sair do mundo das
idéias e transformar isso num projecto
que hoje é referência no mundo todo por
transformar cada espaço verde um espaço
de experimentação de sabores na holanda
um grupo de arquitetos conseguiu
arrecadar mais de 100 euros em três
meses para construir uma passarela junto
com os moradores
eu sei que estão pensando se estão
pensando a carla na europa isso acontece
né
mas nós também temos uma ponte
construída pela comunidade em comunidade
em barra mansa no rio de janeiro
então eu queria contar pra vocês que eu
também tenho experimentado ser uma
produtora na minha cidade e eu tenho
ouvido em três iniciativas que gostaria
de compartilhar com vocês
então desde 2013 eu faço parte do
coletivo o cube e abracem que decidiu
assim que se juntar a preocupar a uma
praça de mais de 12 mil metros quadrados
no meio do bairro da pompeia em são
paulo que deixou de ser usada por medo
dos moradores
imaginem vocês
uma ampla é verde cheia de nascentes no
meio da área urbana não sendo utilizado
a gente precisava dar um valor que esse
espaço merecia o que a gente fez foi
começar com algumas melhorias nessa
praça e criar um festival em dia de
festa chamando os vizinhos para
conhecerem a praça
a gente foi antão dos muros plantando
deixando aflorar até a criação de dois
lagos
hoje a praça é conhecida como a praça da
nascente ea gente conseguiu mostrar os
moradores que esse espaço podia ser um
espaço de lazer e da até de reconexão
com a natureza
a gente sempre soube que nada disso
seria possível se a gente ficar sozinho
a gente precisava de ajuda de outros e
assim a gente conseguiu que
especialistas artistas organizações do
aço no seu tempo por enxergar o valor no
que a gente estava fazendo e nesse
espaço
isso vale para a prefeitura também
porque tem coisas que só eles podem
fazer como a capina de um espaço tão
grande ou recolhimento do lixo é colocar
a praça dentro do sistema de coleta da
cidade ou trocar as lâmpadas públicas
inclusive a gente passou dois anos
lutando por uma reforma estrutural na
praça para torná la mais segura e também
mais divertida para as pessoas poderem
usar ela e valeu muito a pena porque a
gente conseguiu fazer brinquedos praça é
e também transformar um muro que estava
rachado preços a cair numa arquibancada
verde que pudesse ser utilizada por
todos mas nem tudo são flores
não é fácil a gente tem um produtor da
cidade e em 2014 a gente teve um surto
de dengue na cidade e principalmente no
bairro da pompéia e é claro que as
pessoas acharam que a praça era o grande
foco do mosquito
hum a gente pensar o que a gente vê nos
noticiários lançam que a água parada e
pneu
a gente tem que tomar cuidado
e na praça a gente já tinha os dois
lagos e um brinquedo feito por um grupo
espanhol chamado buzz drama que as
crianças amavam todinho de pneu é claro
é que a gente como grupo a gente tinha
esse cuidado de trazer segurança então a
gente curta os pneus e criou um sistema
um ecossistema sustentável para o lago
com entradas e saídas de água com
plantas sacos e peixes e garantiu o fim
lá do mosquito
e aí só que as pessoas não sabiam disso
né no e aí o que aconteceu foi que um
dia a gente chegou na praça não tinha
brinquedo e tinha um agente da anvisa
porque haviam sido denunciados a palavra
isso aqui é o mais curioso é que o
agente ficou encantado com a solução e
disse que essa é uma ótima estratégia
para evitar que essas águas ficaram
encharcados e aí sim que poderia criar
mosquitos então am a gente né ficou
super contente com a resposta dele mas a
gente percebeu que as pessoas que nos
dão iniciaram não tinha como saber por
que ele só saberiam se estivesse de
alguma forma envolvidos com a nossa rede
com nossos eventos
eles fizeram uma associação quase direta
com a informação que eles tinham mas nem
tudo o que parece é que eles não tiveram
paciência nem tentaram conversar com a
gente pra gente chegar a uma solução
o que o coletivo fez bom a gente tentou
abrir esse canal de diálogo ea gente
colocou um cartaz lago este lago combate
o mosquito da dengue
então a gente foi abrir esse canal que
não tinha sido criado
outra iniciativa que eu faço parte ela
aqui de porto alegre
apesar de morar em são paulo eu ando
muito mas muito incomodada com a questão
da segurança não é sobre os nas notícias
de jornal ou as histórias que a gente
escuta por aí mas as mensagens que
recebi dos meus amigos dizendo que foram
assaltados das pessoas que deixam de
sair nas ruas com medo ou eu mesmo
quando veio pra cá louca pra andar
o pé e tem que ficar escutando não pode
só que não são paulo
não dá pra ficar andando a pé isso me
deixa muito incomodado e aí
compartilhando isso com outras pessoas
com amigos e empreendedores a gente é eu
encontrei pessoas que como eu tava afim
de olhar para esse desafio com uma
oportunidade e olhar para as nossas
habilidades e pensar como que a gente
pode utilizá las pra resolver esse
problema
assim nasceu a minha cidade segura que é
um laboratório de inovação e insegurança
pública pra gente olhar porque a gente
já tem recurso que a gente atende ação
de informação e poder transformar isso
em oportunidades a gente vê porto alegre
melhor o que a gente está fazendo na
prática é mapear quem que já atua em
prol da segurança quem tá fazendo
pequenas grandes iniciativas pesquisas
sobre o tema
a gente tem feito conversas com
especialistas e empreendedores de outras
cidades que já desvendaram algumas
possibilidades de solução e fechando
isso disponível em vídeo e gratuitamente
na internet
a gente tem feito encontros presenciais
com especialistas tanto de segurança
quanto de inovação da gente pensar sobre
esse problema e até fizemos um workshop
contra a violência onde a gente consegue
unir poder público e terceiro setor
universidade estudantes polícia
empreendedores empresários alguns
inclusive que estão aqui hoje para a
gente discutir e pensar que o que é esse
desafio na cidade e que oportunidades a
gente já começa a enxergar a gente não é
especialista nenhum de nós é
especialista em segurança mas o que a
gente percebe é que a gente pode fazer
essa conexão entre quem é e esses
produtores que podem gerar e criar novas
soluções não tem sido nada fácil a gente
está desde o ano passado e de fato esse
é um tema difícil porque as empresas não
querem estar conectados a ele
2 por que as pessoas elas estão
desacreditadas
então a gente tem um esforço muito
grande para engajá
e trazer pessoas para essa discussão
olhar isso de uma forma positiva mas a
cada encontro a cada nova descoberta
sobre o tema que a gente tem ea gente
consegue ver que o problema da para
desmembrar ele é menos complexo do que a
gente pensa nos dá um gás a mais nos
motiva a continuar em frente
nosso próximo passo agora é abrir um
laboratório e começar a testar algumas
soluções nos bairros da cidade e último
a última iniciativa que gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês
é uma iniciativa que está acontecendo
dentro do governo e essa é outra boa
notícia
sim existem produtores dentro do governo
que estão afim de fazer coisas
diferentes muitas vezes sozinhos em
nossa secretaria e órgãos públicos no
legislativo pensando em como trazer
inovação e trazer o cidadão mais pra
perto eu eu tenho a sorte de participar
como consultora do pat digital ele é uma
política de inovação aberta da
secretaria de educação da cidade de são
paulo e que acontece em parceria com a
unesco o que o parte faz é buscar a
inovação tecnológica por meio da
transparência e da colaboração com o
cidadão
tá que significa na prática é que a
gente queria serviços novas formas para
impactar o usuário no final na família o
pai a mãe o aluno para entender melhor o
serviço não é um serviço público que
acontece dentro da educação para ajudar
ele na ponta feito junto com esses
servidores fazedores com os professores
com os estudantes e com outros
especialistas que querem estar junto com
a gente porque acreditam que a educação
pode ser melhor
então a gente junta né
é o meu papel nesse processo é facilitar
e potencializar o que eles já fazem é
fazer com que essas trocas aconteçam
usamos metodologia de inovação e design
ajudando para que essa conexão que não é
simples que a gente nunca aprendeu a
fazer ea gente não está acostumado a
fazer aconteça
um professor para conversar com outro
servidor ou entre si
quando eu faço um estudante conversar
com o desenvolvedor é aí que a mágica
acontece é aí que a gente consegue
pensar em soluções que de fato vai
impactar a vida dele não seja no meu
bairro seja pensando na segurança da
minha cidade ou facilitando que essa
inovação ela pode surgir dentro do
governo
o que me motiva é pensar é reativar essa
parte do cérebro de de criação e de
invenção né a reconecta essa
possibilidade de eu não esperava uma
solução pronta embalada com frete grátis
na minha casa né eu consegui criar novas
formas de falar de se fazer
eu aprendi também que sempre vai ter a
pessoa do conta sempre vai ter o cara
que denunciou lago
sempre vai ter um cara que acha que é
uma perda de tempo pensar um problema
tão complexo como a segurança o que é
impossível que alguém de dentro do
governo queira realmente fazer algo novo
e aí que a gente tem nós produtores
temos um outro papel que ajudar esse
consumidor a percorrer esta jornada com
a gente e mostrar que é possível também
fazer a cidade de uma forma diferente
eu acredito que quanto mais rápido a
gente tangibilizar uma idéia uma ação em
um lago um evento em um site internet
a gente consegue mostrar o que a gente
está propondo fica mais fácil para esse
consumidor olhar e se conectar
parece que quando a gente tem algo
tangível experimentar a ver o invisível
e constrói na gente aquela possibilidade
de criação também então para transformar
a cidade
se você me perguntar pra caramba mas
como eu começo né
eu diria para você começar a sentir a
cidade pensa naquilo que mais te
incomoda com a segurança
a mobilidade o pensa naquilo que mais te
empolga que mais chame mínima
as hortas como as crianças uma cidade
feita para crianças uma cidade e
caminhava
a partir dali começa a procurar fontes
alternativas de informação podem ser os
próprios produtores ou coletivos
organizações que já estejam atuando
nesse tema e pode ter certeza
sempre tem alguém com esse mesmo
interesse que a gente pode ser que seja
até de outra cidade e você seja ponte
que precisa para trazer pra cá para a
sua cidade essa mesma solução
agora se você não está a fim de colocar
colocar a mão na massa
tudo bem o seu papel também é muito
importante porque o que nós produtores -
precisamos é de advogado do diabo
sabe aquele dizendo pra gente eo que
está fazendo errado que é uma besteira
que a gente podia fazer melhor
é claro que a gente podia fazer melhor
mas talvez a gente não tem braço para
fazer melhor
quem sabe você pode sair desse papel de
produtor e valorizar e apoiar uma
simples atitude você consegue tornar e
ajudar em algo assim melhor então se
pergunte o que eu posso fazer por minha
cidade hoje obrigada
[Aplausos]